the government is continuing the process
of dismantling the effectively
dismantling the productive core of the
American economy like the automobile
industry it's that's part of the general
financialization the shift of power to
finance to Wall Street that's been going
on for about thirty years so it's not
being destroyed it's just domestically
being destroyed maybe the same
corporations will produce abroad
well that's happening right now it's
causing a disaster in places like
Michigan and Ohio and Indiana it's
destroying home and families communities
meanwhile while this is happening
Obama's Secretary of Transportation is
in Europe visiting Spain trying to work
out contracts whereby say Spain can use
federal stimulus money taxpayer money to
provide the infrastructure structure and
the technology and the mission to know
the equipment for high-speed rail
transport which we desperately need I
mean if if the world's going to survive
we're going to have to get off the the
commitment to very wasteful use of
fossil fuels that's a state corporate
social engineering project the began in
the 1940s and this its leading right to
disaster so you have to reconstitute the
societies will have to be reconstructed
massively and one crucial part of it is
high-speed transit well okay here we
have the government and the corporate
sector dismantling the the the sector or
the industrial apparatus that could very
well produce high-speed transit I mean
the automobile industry could be
retooled for high-speed transit much
more radical steps have been taken so
during the second
war the industry was almost totally
converted the war production that kind
of a semi command economy it was very
successful American industrial
production almost quadrupled it could
surely be done here but instead of doing
that which would make sense for the
population and for our grandchildren it
would help preserve a livable
environment instead of doing that Obama
is sending his Transportation Secretary
to use taxpayer money to get the Spanish
to do it for us there's a commentary on
the social economic system this is just
devastating have you seen a comment
about anywhere
no because it's in the interests of the
sector's the few big interests that in
fact do run the country by now mostly a
financial sector it's profitable for
them so what the public we don't even
know what the public wants because
they're not even asked it's so remote
from consciousness but I suspect that
people would support it and it certainly
could be done